they are coalition colleagues no one
believed could ever come together
here a jewish nationalist and an arab in
the same government
in the foreground there was not even a
glance from the man they've ousted
this is israel's new prime minister
naftali bennett
with his final handshake for the
architect of the coalition
yaya lapide
[Music]
the jias are a hint of just how hard
fought this was
and how fragile it is
our government will make an effort to
deepen and nurture relations with our
friends in both parties
bipartisan if there are disputes we will
manage them
with fundamental trust and mutual
respect
the moment marks the end of an era for
israel for 12 years benjamin netanyahu
has been ever present the
longest-serving pm in israeli history
divisive a master of politics and
defiant to the end
[Music]
[Applause]
we were never friends i never liked him
i never felt close to him i never felt
that he is a genuine human being
was prime minister before netanyahu they
were both from the same party once
he's he's a genius i mean
there will be no one that can compete
with him in on television
lawrence olivier you know
he is he is a great performer but when
you look at the substance
of things the divisions
within the israeli society today are
greater than ever before
internationally it is the palestinian
issue which dominates
and here views are set i think
netanyahu's legacy has been one of the
most
if not the most destructive legacy for
israel
for the whole region and i think in in
many ways by legitimizing
fascism and violence and manipulation
and control
as well as corruption
that he has created a situation where
the chances of peace have become all
that more difficult if not impossible
[Applause]
the victors are always more vocal than
the losers and in central tel aviv they
celebrated the end of an era
back in the knesset a handshake from a
man not used to losing
to the man who has replaced him by a
margin of just one vote
he will serve two years as pm before
handing over to centrist yaya lapid
that is of course if this bizarre
cross-spectrum coalition
lasts that long mark stone sky news in
jerusalem